The Flash becomes God and it's amazing
okay so this is a story a lot of you
guys have asked me to include the name
of the story in the video this is a
story called Flash Forward and this
actually deals with the character of
Wally West and comes hot off the heels
of a story called Heroes and crisis so
one thing to understand here is that
when DC rebooted all of their comics in
2011 meaning you never had to have read
a DC Comic before the new 52 in order to
understand what was going on except for
Green Lantern and Batman what ended up
happening is the original 1990s Wally
West was gone and was nowhere to be
found DC brought him back in a story
called DC Universe rebirth number one
but ever since that story leading up to
this he was just kind of free-floating
through the DC Universe and in fact
almost immediately after that one shot
came out we went into a story called
heroes in crisis you'll find a link to
this story pinned in the comments
section I'll make sure my staff puts it
there but what ended up happening here
is The Flash effectively killed the DC
Universe he ended up losing control of
his powers and there was a whole great
big thing that went on there but then
importance is that in the aftermath of
Heroes in crisis and Wally basically
being the one that killed everybody he's
largely kept himself confined to prison
over fear of the fact that he's a danger
to everybody else now life in the prison
system is exactly as you would expect
for a one-time superhero who was in
there a lot of the prisoners were either
put there by Wally or somebody that he
knows so a lot of them are out for
Revenge he ends up getting his life
saved by another guy who just wants to
watch him suffer but not a whole lot
doing here what is important is that he
ends up getting a visitor in the form of
Linda park now back in the 1990s Linda
Park was the wife and even the mother of
Wally's children giant Iris and that's
where things got really interesting
after his return to DC Comics because
basically nobody remembered him we ended
up finding out that the reason why
everybody forgot was because Dr
Manhattan from the Watchman Universe
basically rewrote the history of the DC
Universe and one of the things that he
had done is he had basically removed
Wally West and put him in the speed
force so even when he came back because
of the fact that Dr man hadn't had
meddled with everything his kids were
missing nobody knew where were Linda
Park did not ever remember having been
married to him and Barry only was able
to bring him back because at the very
last moment Barry remembered who Wally
was and was able to pull him out of the
speed force but that's why Wally is kind
of a man almost out of time right he's
in a world that should remember him but
nobody does and so even when he's
talking to Linda Park he has like this
drive and inclination to refer to her as
his wife to talk about the life that
they had together and in fact he almost
tried that and I think he actually did
try that I'm not going to swear by that
right like 100 head cannon on that one
so we're not going to uh we're not going
to take that as an absolute but the long
and short is that he doesn't really kind
of expose these things to her and in
fact she even tries to tell him look
everybody knows it was an accident he
lost control of your powers yada yada
but he ends up basically just kind of
keeping himself confined here now in the
midst of all this what ends up happening
while he's being attacked in this prison
is he suddenly yanked Away by a guy who
has one of the most ridiculous names in
the history of comics a guy named
Tempest fudgina now this guy is what we
in the comic book Community refer to as
a device because this guy shows up for
arbitrary reasons and you never see or
hear from him unless DC needs to just do
something with a Multiverse
it's exactly how this dude works but it
is really cool when he does show up
because in a lot of ways he's kind of DC
Comics version of The Watcher from
Marvel Comics as owatu but the thing
about this is that he basically tells
Wally you are in need right like we need
a person to go into the Multiverse and
basically start fixing things now the
funny thing about this is that this
story as it's originally written is
seemingly supposed to be self-contained
what you're going to see towards the end
of this is that DC is actually going to
segue it into the Batman who laughs and
that's why seemingly his involvement is
going to kind of come out of nowhere
it's not overly complex here and you
only see him for a brief Glimpse but it
was a way for DC to tie into like the
death metal event that was going on at
the time the bigger thing about this is
that Wally West initially rejects this
Mission by Tempest because this argument
is I killed all the superheroes on my
Earth and sure they use some time travel
Shenanigans to bring everybody back to
life but why in the world would I be
even remotely equipped to go on a
mission like this now there's two things
I want you to notice in this comic and
it's one of the reasons why wall West
fans were not the biggest fan of it the
first is because Wally West spends like
the first part of the comic very woe is
me I'm so sad I killed all the
superheroes and I could never forgive
myself right he's like every 13 year old
girl ever but the other part of this is
that the comic is not really written in
modern vernacular so to speak right it
doesn't feel like a comic that was
written in
2019-2020 what it felt like is a comic
written from the 90s which I loved I
actually love the way this comic was
done but the bigger thing about this is
that Wall-E is just kind of Thrust out
into the Multiverse to basically deal
with what is this sort of growing
existence of what's called dark matter
it's very ambiguous and very nebulous
and even Tempest doesn't give direct
answers to Wally therefore we don't get
direct answers but one of the first
things that happens is he's transported
to what's basically Earth 23 the home of
President Superman now president
Superman is basically just a Superman
who became president of the United
States in a different reality and he
still leaves the Justice League and so
on and so forth now the thing about this
is that once Wally gets there one thing
to understand here and this is a very
important distinction yes a lot of what
we saw from Wally West in the 1990s from
Mike Barron and then Mark Wade and then
Grant Morrison and then Mark Wade again
a little bit of Jeff John's here and
there to a degree dealt with like some
multiversal hijinks but back then final
crisis hadn't necessarily happened even
Infinite Crisis hadn't happened so the
Multiverse didn't truly Exist by and
large the stories of Wally West dealt
with events like terminal velocity where
you learned the origin of the speed
force different things like that right
the story by Grant Morrison or Wally
West outran the universe things along
those lines right you'll also find links
to those down in the comments section
I'm pretty sure we covered all those
stories and if we didn't we'll make
videos on them but the reason why I
mention all this is because Wally is not
overly familiar with the Multiverse in
the same way that Barry Allen is he is
familiar with it he's been through it
but his knowledge isn't necessarily on
the same level as Barry so that's why
some of the things that you're going to
see here with Wally encountering these
different realities very much seems
foreign to him and even the process of
being thrust through the Multiverse
feels strange to him to a degree but
what we end up finding out is that
President Superman basically just got
wrecked and the reason why is because
there's just like these dark matter
beings that exist out there that are for
whatever reason attacking virtually
everything they see now of course Wally
is able to help President Calvin to a
degree and of course what this does is
it leads to the Justice League stepping
in now the Justice League steps in
because they don't know who Wally is
they initially see him as an enemy of
course President Calvin clears
everything up says no no we're cool
we're on the same side but what he says
is that these dark matter beings that
are out there are on a level of power
that he hasn't really experienced before
more so than that with a physical
Onslaught he feels something a little
off about himself what's really going on
is he has an effect been infected by
that dark matter but more so than that
what he does is he deduces two things
right first these monster things are not
native to their reality and two they are
representative of what is in effect the
corruption of different universes by way
of this dark matter that exists out
there and so as soon as he basically
elicits the help of Wally and trying to
deal with this Wally immediately blasts
him with his staff that was given to him
by Tempest in order to Traverse the
entirety of the Multiverse and then
takes off now the Justice League
immediately sees this as an attack which
kind of makes sense because by all
standards a measurement it basically was
right the motivation behind doing this
will become clear as we make our way
through but what ends up happening is
that in this attack Wally takes off and
then basically arrives at these dark
matter beings only to in turn also be
met with other superheroes from this
world called the retaliators now of
course he's able to overcome these guys
quite readily they're not much of a
challenge for him one part due to his
super speed and the other part due to
the fact that they're not 100 sure
exactly how to handle him and none of
them are really all that special in the
first place but what is important is
that once he makes his way to these dark
matter monsters that get here what he
ends up learning is there's also like
this anti-life bomb that's making its
way towards the entirety of the planet
and it's gonna blow everything up the
important thing here is that between
using his staff to blast President
Calvin or president Superman as well as
arriving here on the scene and using it
against this dark matter though what he
hadn't effectively done was purified
president Superman of the Dark Matter
infection which allowed him to stop the
bomb and then in turn using the staff
was able to dissipate this dark matter
energy and then essentially the day is
saved jump to the next reality right so
it's just kind of small little moments
like that none of what he's doing here
is significant or huge or meaningful in
any real important way and that's one of
the reasons why this story was kind of
met with mixed reactions because people
saw it and they were kind of like I mean
there's a lot more that DC could have
done here besides what we ended up
getting in the here and now but the
other part of this is that once he jumps
to the next reality you have all these
different people who are basically being
dumped out of a giant Cruise Ship by
Superman and once he gets to where
Superman is he ends up finding out it's
a vampire Superman so this is the
reality in DC Comics which the numerical
designation I don't remember but it's
the reality where basically all the
superheroes are vampires now Superman
does this because he's like my vampire
people need to eat right that kind of
thing but the other cool thing here is
that Wally basically beats Superman
within an inch of his life and in fact
he even deduces that while this Superman
does have the same strengths and
weaknesses of the Superman that he's
used to including green Kryptonite the
vampire aspect of him offers an
additional week weakness that he
wouldn't normally have that of course
being wood now under normal
circumstances trying to stab Superman in
the chest with wood it does allow Wally
to basically stab Superman with pieces
of wood and at the very least subdue him
only to be met by the Barry Allen the
flash of this universe who's also a
vampire now again hunting down this kind
of dark matter you end up having Wally
kind of fighting Barry to a degree and
then in the middle of this you end up
having the two of them being met by Roy
Harper now at the moment the Roy Harper
appears this actually leads to Wally
using the speed force to basically
incinerate Barry Allen right to destroy
him on the spot but when Roy Harper
shows up here in this reality he's a
vampire hunter he's one of the very few
people out there who are not infected
and so working alongside Wally who he
doesn't initially trust he ends up
taking Wally to the location of what is
believed to be this dark matter within
the universe when they get there they
end up finding out that it's in the one
place you would probably expect it to be
the bat cave because when you have a
dark and brooding Batman who just sits
around all day smoking cigarettes
listening to The Cure of course Dark
Matter energy is gonna coalesce there so
what is it happening
is once they get in there Batman in the
most bat way ever descends from the
ceiling because he's just been hanging
upside down there and then he comes to
the realization or at least had come to
the realization somewhere along the line
after studying this dark matter that
because of the kind of properties that
it possesses he could actually use it as
an energy source for all of his own
people for the various vampires across
his own Planet they end up defeating
Batman but in one of the coolest ways
Roy Harper dies right literally where
Harper just gets slashed across the
chest so good job Wally West on leading
Roy Harper to his own Doom but then
what's also going on inside the bad cave
is there's a kind of nuclear reactor
when Batman goes to attack Wally West
and probably one of the coolest moments
ever Wally vibrates him into the heart
of his nuclear reactor now that's one of
the things I do want to establish here
right it's actually one of the big
differences between Wally West and Barry
Allen so depending on who you talk to
and this is a debate that's been raging
since really since like the 1990s right
Wally West fans versus Barry Allen fans
who's more powerful in general Wally
West is largely considered to be more
powerful than Barry Allen because where
Barry Allen quote unquote Taps into the
speed force Wally West does What's
called mainlining the speed force
meaning he's part and parcel to the
speed force itself almost like a
physical manifestation of it not only
that Wally West also has abilities that
Barry didn't initially have but has
gained over the years being able to give
his speed force to other people right
being able to vibrate in ways that Barry
Allen Sibley couldn't do the infinite
Mass punch right things along those
lines and so the kind of things that
you're seeing Wally West pull here
aren't necessarily things that DC is
just pulling out of their backside
because the plot demands it its powers
and abilities that Wally's had for
decades within DC Comics so it's stuff
has been around for a long long time now
of course Roy Harper ends up dying which
you know destroy Harper like the guy
always does but following this he ends
up jumping to another reality where you
basically have super demon etrigan now
things are a little murky here because
it's not just one reality that Wally
West is visiting here in fact it's two
realities that are being merged Together
by The Dark Matter energy that is
permeating throughout the entirety of
the Multiverse now this is a universe
known as Earth 13. this is a reality
where in effect you don't really have
traditional superheroes the way you know
them right so you don't have Superman
you've got super etricant but in effect
magic and sorcery rule the landscape
here but the cool thing here is that
when Wally starts to realize that
something bigger is going on he's yanked
Away by Tempest fudginat who basically
gives him the bigger picture and saying
you're not dealing with just one reality
here you're dealing with two so what
you're gonna have to do is find a way to
quite literally push universes apart now
again referencing Grant Morrison's
terminal velocity Wally West outrunning
the universe these are things that even
on some level he's tapped into before
but basically harnessing the ability to
separate entire universes is no small
thing and in fact it's an incredibly
difficult task to achieve so much so
that he can't even do it on his own but
in the midst of all this this crazy
conflict and Madness and whatnot he's
met by a alternate reality version of a
Linda Park Opera turning under the name
Lightspeed who had gained the powers of
the flash now of course this Linda does
not know who Wally West is and in true
Wally West Fashions Oh Linda you know
I'm your husband and we have kids you
know yada yada but the thing about this
is that the two of them basically end up
teaming up Linda doesn't initially do it
willingly and in fact she doesn't know
him so she doesn't necessarily trust him
but she gets this kind of feeling where
she's like well yeah I don't have a
reason to believe that you would turn
against me this is absolutely plot stuff
that's really all this is right but what
ends up going on is between the two of
them working together channeling the
power of the speed force and then using
the staff given by Tempest fudge not
they're able to cleanse both the
universes of this dark matter and then
split Both Worlds Apart thereby keeping
these incursions from happening and
sending Wally back on his journey again
now the crazy thing about this is that
as he's continuing on he finally
stumbles across what is in effect his
final destination and this is what
appears to be a reality where all the
different superheroes that he's known
over the course of his life whether it's
because of his actions and heroes in
crisis or because because they were
superheroes that he had worked alongside
at one point along the line but had died
they're all kind of manifested here in
almost a sort of Tombstone or Memorial
to a degree that's dedicated to these
guys but the other thing about this is
that where even Wally himself was
questioning whether or not the life he
remembered having was a life that he
actually did have when he gets here he's
met by his kids giant Iris and so this
is like one of the first times in DC
Comics post DC rebirth where the two of
them had cropped up now if you're not a
massive fan of Wally West this moment is
lost on you and understandably so but if
you are a huge fan of Wally West and you
got to be a part of it when his
character returned to the DC Universe
this was huge because the big question
that a lot of fans had is Will Wally get
his life back what a lot of people
really longed for even when the new 52
kicked off is they were longing for like
Jeff John's flash rebirth right where
the story comes to an end and you've got
every member of The Flash family just
racing off right towards what's
basically the reader Kiba wanted to see
that this kind of real unification of
all the flashes that they knew but
seeing the reuniting of Wally and giant
Iris basically it was DC telling comic
book fans yes we're bringing the whole
family back together Wally is going to
go back to having the life that you
remember him having when he was being
written by Mike Barron Mark Wade and
Grant Morrison and so what is going on
is that when he's here basically it's
kids tell him you have to run like we
have to run and get out of here as fast
as possible the caveat to this is
despite having Speedster Powers they
haven't been able to leave as if the
planet itself is keeping them there no
matter how hard they run no matter what
the case is they can't seem to pull it
off now there's two main reasons for why
this is happening the first reason is
because they're not as fast as their
father and so the ability of giant Iris
to basically run at the speed of light
and potentially run this border between
going so fast that they could
potentially enter the speed force but
not fast enough and allowing them to
stay inside the real intangible World
they haven't really reached that point
yet and so because because of that they
can't really transcend or they can't
vibrate out of the reality and into
another one but the other part of this
is that even when they did try to do
that despite not being able to master
that ability the planet still wouldn't
let them leave the reason for that is
because it's all Wally West that the
reality here and one of the things that
Wally West begins to piece together is
that this world is not an arbitrary
world that exists out there right it's
not just some random Place some universe
that came into existence that in fact
what he's told by Tempest as he starts
to figure these things out is Tempest
tells him this is a world that's not
supposed to exist it's not native to the
Multiverse meaning it didn't come into
existence with this multiversal big bang
and all these different realities
started popping up instead the reason
why it's populated by all these sort of
stone monuments to everyone that you've
known and fought alongside and even
killed during Heroes and crisis is
because this is a world composed of your
greatest fears your greatest fear was
losing your children so what happened
you lost your children now there is a
reason why all that took place and again
we'll talk a little bit more about that
but the bigger Point here is that the
world is composed of everything he's
afraid of so even during the events of
Heroes in crisis when his actions had
led to the deaths of superheroes that's
why these different monuments these
different superheroes started popping up
because he was afraid of what he could
do if he regained his powers that fear
was predicated on an existing action and
subconsciously he started feeding it
into this world that he has been
unintentionally creating all this dark
matter that exists out there is his fear
taking on a physical manifestation and
permeating all of creation Now the other
reason why Wally is able to figure so
much of this out is that even where
tempus was very very Cloak and Dagger
about information that he could give him
and simply just chose not to that when
the time came when Wally tried to use
his powers and realizing the world was
created by Him to basically undo the
world Itself by eradicating all this
dark matter energy in the midst of it
all he was suddenly met by the arrival
of the Mobius chair now the Mobius chair
was one of these artifacts in DC Comics
that pops up and is relative to whatever
Stories being told at the time a good
example of this dark side War right the
Mobius tear was just a chair that was
housed by Metatron that he would just
travel around the Multiverse and he
would Chronicle everything he saw and
basically store it within the Mobius
chair as a kind of library with infinite
books inside and then in turn Metatron
was basically taken out and so what
ended up happening is the Mobius chair
has not really had an inhabitant ever
since Batman did have it for a period of
time which is one of the things that DC
used to go into a story about the three
Jokers when Batman realized there were
actually three different Jokers which is
why his identities seemed to shift
around but the bigger thing about this
is that once Wally realizes and even
enters the chair to a degree asks it a
question and gets an answer he comes to
this realization the only way to
basically save the Multiverse to prevent
this corruption from sort of spinning
out into the rest of all of creation is
to destroy the very world that he's on
now in reality he doesn't want to and a
lot of it's because he's just kind of
caught up in the emotion of the moment
being there with giant Iris and in a lot
of ways it was DC teasing the idea that
in order to save all of creation his
kids would have to die now I got to tell
you right off the bat fans weren't
having that because if you had a chance
to check out like the forums or Twitter
or anything that was going on in
relation to this the one thing Wally
West fans were saying is please do not
take the kids away again please do not
do that let us have these kids and so
what ends up happening is Wally West
basically tells Tempest okay I will
eradicate this world in eradicating my
fears but in doing so make sure my kids
stay safe make sure you get them back
home and that's exactly what he does now
here's the other part of the equation
right the other part of this that when
everything was kicking off with regards
to DC Universe rebirth number one and Dr
Manhattan messing with everything and
putting Wally West inside the speed
force that his fears basically
manifested within that place because
while Wally was in the speed force it's
not as though he was unconscious he
remembered everything the life that he
had before and all that kind of stuff he
didn't know what had led to all of it he
didn't know that Dr Manhattan had put
him there and he didn't know that it was
the events of Flashpoint that led to Dr
Manhattan intervening in the first place
because remember that was kind of the
crack that allowed Dr Manhattan in in
the first place that when Barry Allen
went back in time to save his mom's life
and then that initiated the the
flashpoint Paradox the doctor man hadn't
used that in the moment where Barry
Allen went back a second time and let
his mom die Dr Manhattan used that to
recreate reality right to restructure it
and treat it as like a kind of giant
petri dish what happens if I move Alan
Scott's original Green Lantern just
slightly over there like three feet to
the left then Alan Scott dies because he
never finds a lantern and the Justice
Society of America never gets formed and
so the Justice League never comes into
existence right the butterfly effect and
so it was that kind of thing that
Manhattan was doing that was all covered
during the Doomsday Clock storyline
which was phenomenal but the thing about
this is that with Wally being stuck
there the fears that he had in losing
his children the kind of pain and
anguish he experienced over the the fact
that that fear had come to fruition
that's what permeated because remember
when you're part and parcel to the speed
force the way that Wally West was your
fears and your dreams can become reality
in that place you're as close to God as
any one person can be and in fact DC's
hypothesize hasn't really given us a
definitive answer but sort of alluded to
the idea that the speed force is part of
the source itself right the source of
all creation but regardless of how you
choose to look at it this is how Wally
West fears and his worries and concerns
were able to create this kind of
tangential Universe out there where all
these things reside and so once he makes
the decision to eradicate this entire
world he dons the Mobius chair and in
doing so inherits a portion of Dr
Manhattan's powers and so this is the
story where Wally West becomes Dr
Manhattan now of course in that moment
because of the fact that he's dawn of
the chair because the world has been
destroyed and effectively he's conquered
his fears things start snapping back
right the world goes to the way that it
should be in terms of remembering Wally
West a great example of this is that
while Linda Parks on the phone suddenly
she remembers Wally and she remembers
giant Iris and she's like where in the
world are you guys right like what's
going on because it's her remembering
that they exist but also remembering
that she doesn't remember them
right and so as soon as she sees them
there then she immediately runs through
her kits and the first question is like
where's your dad and so with Wally West
on the morbius chair and having the
doctor Manhattan symbol on his head this
new level of godly power that he's never
experienced before what it does is it
goes into a story called generation zero
where in effect not only is Wally West
going to basically rewrite reality but
DC is actually going to adjust his
entire backstory to make him fit more in
line with the post DC Universe rebirth
landscape but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace